[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: OK, thanks very
much for inviting me here.
I'll kind of organize my
talk into different bits.
So I'll go through
these sections--
Me and My Project, Some History,
the events from September
the 14th to February the 11th,
the Event and its Reception.
You know, this is the discovery
of gravitational waves,
the first confirmed detection
of gravitational waves announced
at a press conference on
February the 11th, 2016.
But the actual event was seen
on September the 15th, 2015.
And a few more
things at the end,
some which might be
quite interesting.
And I'll head each of
the sections with this.
So we'll see how
we're getting along.
I'll try and talk
for about 30 minutes
and leave plenty of time
for questions and answers
because there usually
are various questions.
So let's start with
me of my project.
I've been doing this for--
I think this is the 45th
year, not 30th year.
At least, I started in 1972.
Those were the
first interviews I
conducted on what was
then the controversy
over gravitational waves.
I'll talk a bit more
about that in a moment.
And these are some of the books.
"Gravity's Shadow," which
is a very thick book,
it's about over 800 pages
long, nearly 900 pages,
which was published in 2004.
My advice is not to buy it
because once you start reading
it, you'll never put it down.
And it will waste
a lot of your time.
[LAUGHTER]
And the second-- that
book, "Gravity's Ghost,"
is actually two books in one.
One book is called "Gravity's
Ghost," which was originally
published separately by itself.
And then the second book
was called "Big Dog,"
and I persuaded the
publishers to include
"Gravity's Ghost" in the
publication of "Big Dog."
So this book is the
paperback version
of "Gravity's Ghost," as
well as being the paperback
version of "Big Dog."
There was never a
hardback version of it.
And what that book describes is
two so-called blind injections.
This is when the
big interferometric
gravitational wave
detectors were in business.
I'll explain that in a moment.
And what the scientist did
was get a small group, two
or three people, to inject
into the interferometers
a signal which looked
like a gravitational wave
and keep it secret so that
the whole community had
to investigate this signal
not knowing whether it was
a real signal or a fake signal.
So they were rehearsing for
the detection of a real signal,
not knowing whether
they were already
looking at a real signal, to
make it as valid as possible.
One of the things that
the book talks about a lot
is whether these blind
injections were really
mimicking a real detection
of gravitational waves.
Because now, we had
the real detection
of gravitational waves.
This book is a real-time account
from the evening of September
the 15th, 2015, when I first
read the mail that said,
interesting event has
happened, for about six months,
until the thing
was out in public.
And then it goes on
about the reception of it
in public and so forth.
It's all written in real time,
or mostly real time anyway.
I didn't start
writing it until--
the event happened on a Monday.
And I didn't start writing
the book until the Thursday
because I assumed it
wasn't a real event,
just like all the other
scientists did as well.
You know, they thought, this
is another bit of noise.
But then it grew
rapidly in credibility
over about two days.
And then I realized, hey,
this is something interesting
going on here, and I started
to write on the Thursday,
just having collected
the emails up till then.
And it was obviously
interesting from the word
go to be worth collecting
the emails, which I did.
Incidentally, I'll tell
you how I wrote this book.
I mean, I've been at this for
donkey's years, as you see.
And my method is
mostly initially,
to interview the scientists.
In 1972, I drove across
America in an old car
talking to all
the scientists who
were involved in
gravitational wave detection.
And then from the
mid-90s to the mid-2000s,
I went to every single
gravitational wave conference
that took place around
the world and got
to know the gravitational
wave scientists really well.
I mean, one of the
very senior people
was staying with
us for the weekend
just last weekend, actually,
because we've become friends.
And so I did an awful
lot of traveling.
I used an awful lot of air
miles, enough air miles
to travel business
class wherever
I went for about 10 years,
because I had all these air
miles.
I can't do it anymore,
unfortunately.
And so I was going to maybe six,
seven international meetings
a year across the world.
But this event, I
assumed, was going
to involve me in a hell of
a lot of airplane travel.
But it didn't because
the whole thing happened
over email, emails, a few
telecoms, a few telephone
calls.
Obviously, people were
talking to each other
in their local groups.
Remember, this is a group
of 1,200 people scattered
around the world.
And they did not at any
time during the course
of this discovery meet
together in one place.
They did it all by
email and by telecom.
And I was just sitting in the
middle of this web of emails
and telecoms collecting them.
Now, the question
is, why on Earth--
why me?
If you want to know
something about the detection
of gravitational waves, why
have you invited a sociologist?
I'm a sociologist,
for heaven's sake.
OK, and this is a fairly
serious question for me too.
Am I capable of writing
about the detection
of gravitational waves?
And the answer is yes.
But I'm going to justify
this a little bit more
than I might normally.
Let me say one justification
is that when I write stuff,
I send it to the gravitational
wave physicists and say,
read this and tell me if
there's anything wrong with it.
I've never had any
serious problem.
But you know, we
have a few odds.
You know, you're
saying that, Harry.
That's not true.
And I say, well, I
think it is true.
And we argue backwards
and forwards.
And generally, when I have a
serious conversation like that,
I'll alter maybe half of
the points that I object to
and leave the other
half as the were.
That's the kind of way it goes.
But I'm going to talk
a little bit more
about why it is that I am
capable of writing this book.
Because I think one of the tests
I did is of particular interest
to you guys.
And there you are.
There's a piece in "Nature,"
"Sociologist Fools Physics
Judges."
That's me.
I'm the sociologist.
And I did it by playing
imitation games,
which, of course, are the
forerunner of the Turing test.
So I thought you might be
slightly interested in these.
And what this "Nature"
article is reporting
is something we did
in 2005-6, where
I got a gravitational physicist
from my university department
in Cardiff.
Cardiff is, by coincidence,
by complete coincidence,
quite a big place for
gravitational wave physics.
So I got one of the guys
from there, a professor
from there, to
ask some questions
of me and a gravitational
wave physicist.
And then we had
three dialogues--
me, the question there, the
answer from Respondent A
there, the answer from
Respondent B there.
This was sent to nine other
gravitational wave physicists.
They were technical questions.
And the nine other gravitational
wave physicists were asked,
which one's the real
gravitational wave physicist?
We've done a lot in Cardiff.
Me and my group have done a
lot more imitation games since.
We got a very nice 2 1/4 million
European Research Council
advanced grant to use imitation
games as a new social science
method.
And we're just writing a
book about imitation games
for MIT Press.
And then we repeated
this experiment.
Those are the questions.
Wait a minute.
Let me just-- Sorry.
We repeated the experiment.
So these are the results for
some much more recent versions
of it in 2016.
If you want to know what
the questions were like,
I've given you the
2016 questions.
Don't bother to read through
all those eight questions.
Just pick one or
two at random so you
get a sense of the nature of
the questions being asked.
This wasn't trivial stuff.
OK, this was quite a
reasonably hard test.
Same professor of physics at
Cardiff asked those questions.
OK.
And here's the
results of that test.
So on the left-hand
side of the table,
you see that the question is--
this time we elaborated.
We got not just me,
but other people
to answer the
questions, not just
me and a gravitational
wave physicist.
We got three gravitational
wave physicists
to answer the questions.
We got what I call
three savvy physicists
to answer the questions.
Now, savvy physicists
are astrophysicists
working in the same
department, Cardiff department,
as the gravitational
wave physicists.
So they knew a lot about
gravitational waves
from working in the
same department,
as well as being
astrophysicists themselves.
Two savvy social scientists--
and savvy social scientists
are people like my
junior colleagues
at Cardiff, who have to
read everything I ever
write and listen to me
talking at enormous length
about gravitational
wave physics.
So they know quite a
bit about it as well.
And me, Harry Collins.
And then on the right,
going across the top,
you see the people who
marked the answers.
The people who
marked the answers
were another four
gravitational wave physicists,
four different ones entirely.
OK?
The same two savvy
social scientists--
it may have already struck you
that there's a problem here
because there are people
marking their own answers.
But actually, it's
less of a problem
than you think because
the marking was
done a long time after the
questions were being asked.
And there are 72 randomly
ordered questions.
And it's not actually
so easy to recognize
which question you'd answered.
So it's a little bit messy,
but it's not too bad.
OK, two ordinary
social scientists
who knew nothing about
gravitational wave
physicists especially, because
they weren't under my control,
and me, myself.
So the first thing to look
down is the left-hand column.
And you'll see the way the four
gravitational wave physicists--
you could get a
maximum of 32 points
if you answered
every question right.
And the three other
gravitational wave physics
got an average of
27 points, and I
got 25 points, which isn't bad,
whereas the non-gravitational
wave physicists,
crucially, including
the savvy physicists
who didn't know anything
about gravitational waves,
got considerably less points.
And there's an
interesting lesson
in this very little
small experiment,
which is that expertises
are like crevasses.
They're very narrow and deep.
And it's not the
case that if you're
a scientist in a white coat,
you can go up and pronounce
authoritatively on any similar
subject that's close to yours.
And this little tiny
experiment shows it.
And even a snotty-nosed
sociologist
like me can do better in
answering those questions
than a physicist who
has spent a lot of time
near to other gravitational
wave physicists.
Well, there's more
in that table.
We can come back to it in the
question session if you want.
But I don't want to spend
the whole lecture on that.
So some history of this.
The first person to have tried
to detect gravitational waves--
Einstein worked out
these were a consequence
of the theory of relativity
in the early 20th century.
He worked out not the wave form,
but some of their properties
when he worked out the general
theory of relativity in 1915.
The detection,
which was in 2015,
was miraculously just 100 years
after Einstein had come up
with a detailed idea.
But the first person
to try and detect them
was Joe Weber, this
guy here, shown here,
who started to try
and detect them
in the early '60s with
a device like this.
That thing he's working on
is a cylinder of aluminum,
weighing a ton-and-a-half or
a couple of tons, suspended,
insulated in a vacuum tube.
It has piezoelectric
crystals glued
to its surface, which will
sense any slight vibration
in the cylinder.
And the trick is to have
two of these cylinders
a couple of thousand
miles apart and look
for co-incident excitations
in the two cylinders.
And what you see
is if this happens,
if you've eliminated all sources
of vibration in the cylinders--
you can't.
They're always jiggling
about from Brownian motion
and residual vibrations
coming up through the Earth
that you haven't quite
managed to damp out,
and residual 60 mains
frequency and things
like that that's coming
through the electrical system.
But if you can eliminate
most of that stuff.
And then you see a couple of big
excursions happening at exactly
the same time, or
to be more exact,
within the light travel
time between the two
2,000-miles-an-hour detectors.
OK?
You say, well, I can't think
what could have caused this.
So we'll call that
gravitational waves.
OK?
You can think of some things
that could have caused it.
If you get a lightning strike
somewhere in between the two
detectors, well,
they could cause it.
And the other thing,
the sort of thing
that people used
to worry about is,
what if this happens
on Monday night
in America when everybody's
watching Monday Night Football?
And at the interval,
they all got up
and switched their kettles on.
That's going to send a pulse
through the grid at exactly
the same time.
And that could fool you.
You might think
that's a gravity wave.
But so wipe out all
that sort of stuff.
And you try and measure
all that sort of stuff.
And you try and get to
a gravitational wave.
That's a schematic of
Joe Weber's design.
Another half dozen people tried
to repeat Joe Weber's findings.
Pretty well, completely,
they didn't confirm it.
And that's when I come in
1972, going around interviewing
both lots of scientists
and trying to work out
how they argue with
each other and how
they come to a conclusion.
So that was my earliest work.
And yeah, let's see that.
So with that technology,
which was improved--
the next generation
of these resonance
bars was cooled down
to near absolute zero.
They're quite difficult.
So Joe Weber's apparatus
must have cost a few tens
of thousands of dollars.
And then you're getting
into the hundreds
of thousands of dollars' worth
of cryogenically cooled bars.
A big center for this
were Italy, as well as
the United States.
And over the period
up to the early 2000s,
about half a dozen
claims were made
to have detected gravitational
waves with this technology.
But they were all
shot down eventually
by the scientific community.
That's an important piece of
context to the discovery when
it did happen, because you've
got to realize that when
these people were
thinking they were seeing
a gravitational
wave in 2015, this
was against a background of
nearly 50 years of shooting
down every single claim that
had ever been made to have seen
a gravitational wave.
And there was a lot of paranoia
about and a lot of enmity
about because the rest
of the physics community
generally felt that
their money was
being wasted by
these idiots trying
to detect gravitational waves.
I should add that--
I should have said this before.
The point about
gravitational waves
is they're very, very,
very difficult to detect.
So how are they produced?
They're produced
by moving masses.
So just as
electromagnetic waves are
produced by moving
electrons, my fist
here is producing
gravitational waves
because I'm moving it about.
How much?
Well, probably about a quantum
of energy in the lifetime
of a couple of universes.
When Einstein worked
out the formula
for the emission of
gravitational waves,
in the denominator was a
factor of the speed of light
to the power of four.
That just gives you a
sense of how difficult
to detect these things are.
We'll come back to
that in a minute.
So half a dozen
claims were made.
And the point is that if
Joe Weber had been right
and he'd really been detecting
gravitational waves, according
to the theory, either
something very funny
would must have been
going on, like there
was a very local source
which we couldn't see--
I mean, really local--
emitting the waves
that he was saying.
But most people
thought the waves
ought to be coming from
the center of the galaxy,
if he was seeing them.
Either that, or
so much energy was
being produced in
gravitational radiation
that the Milky Way should have
been burning up before our eyes
and disappearing.
And people were
upset by that idea.
And so they didn't really want
to accept Joe Weber's findings,
nor any of the
subsequent findings.
So that's the early technology.
Then the technology slowly
and gradually moved over
to interferometry.
An interferometer-- who doesn't
know what an interferometer is?
Hands up.
OK, an interferometer is
a device with two arms.
There you can see the two arms.
OK?
You go from a center station.
You shine light
down the two arms.
The light is reflected back
from mirrors at the end.
And then the reflected
light is combined
on a screen in the middle.
And if that light
is coherent, you
will see a pattern of light
and dark so-called fringes,
light and dark
stripes on the screen.
OK?
And the light and
dark stripes are
caused by the interference
of the two beams of light
coming back and
meeting each other.
They're dark where
a trough and a peak
coincide and cancel
each other out.
They're bright where
two peaks or two troughs
coincide and double the effect.
So you get these light
and dark troughs.
Now, supposing you minutely
increase the length of one
of the arms, then
the position where
the light and dark troughs
will meet each other
will be slightly different.
So what you will see is
that that pattern of fringes
moves slightly
across the screen.
And this is an incredibly
sensitive instrument.
Now, I've built one.
I've built a lot of
these actually myself,
just a homemade one.
And you can do it.
And I'm going to
write another book
about gravitational waves
in which I'll give you
instructions on how to do it.
But it's pretty easy.
Mine has arms about--
my typical one has arms
about eight inches long.
The source of light
is a laser pointer.
OK?
The mirrors are just bits
of broken shaving mirror.
You don't need anything fancy.
You need here a
beam splitter, which
should be something like
a semi-silvered mirror.
But I've discovered any
old bit of glass will do.
I just use a bit of glass out
of a picture frame from IKEA.
And you can produce
interference fringes, not nice,
neat lined-up ones,
pretty rough ones.
But nevertheless,
you can see that they
are interference fringes,
light and dark, the light
and dark pattern.
And you can test this out.
So this little type of
interferometer that I built
is made out of a
chip board as a base.
And if you've get
a cup of coffee
and put it down on the
base somewhere near where
one of the beams is,
the wood will expand,
and you will see the
expansion of that wood
as a movement of the
light and dark patches.
And when you take the coffee
back, pick your coffee cup up,
that expansion will
slowly go back again.
And then you can put your
coffee cup near the other beam,
and you will see the
movement of the fringes
in the other direction and
back again and so forth.
So it's quite a nice
fun instrument to build.
I just did that
for myself, to help
myself be more of a participant
in the whole gravitational wave
business.
So I once took it to a
physicist, a gravitational wave
physicists' conference
and said, well,
do you want to display this?
And they sneered at me.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
Because, of course,
their interferometers
are somewhat more sensitive.
The interferometers used in
the detection instrument,
the arms are four
kilometers long.
OK?
The lasers are
extraordinarily powerful.
And the light doesn't just
bounce four kilometers
and come back.
It bounces backwards
and forwards
100 times before they recombine
it, and so on and so on and so
on and so on and so on.
These things are probably--
no, I don't way probably.
They are the most sensitive
large-scale instruments
that have ever
been built. It may
be that they're the most
sensitive instruments that
have ever been built.
But they're certainly
the most sensitive
large-scale instruments that
have ever been built.
So that kind of
interferometry took over
from about the early
2000s or late 1990s.
And there was a big war
between the people championing
the interferometer
technology, which
costs hundreds of
millions of dollars,
and the people championing the
resonant bar technology, which
costs $100,000.
There was a big
war between them.
And one of the things I
document in my earlier books
is how this war played out, how
they won, and what happened.
But by now, the resonant
bars are almost forgotten.
Those are the two big
interferometers in America,
one in Hanford in
Washington State,
one in Livingston, Louisiana.
And there, you can see
the four-kilometer arms
stretching into the distance
and the center station.
And it was these instruments
that made the discovery.
There are two generations
of these instruments.
The initial LIGO
was built about--
well, it was taken down
about five or six years ago.
And they used the
same housings to put
in bigger mirrors, more powerful
lasers, various other things
like this, better
suspension and so on so
that it would work still better.
And that was ready for
business in the autumn of 2015.
February the 11th was
the press conference,
which you may have seen.
It was all over all the news
bulletins when that gravity
waves had been discovered.
I was up here in London,
because they had a little press
conference in London.
I went to that.
And down in the basement of the
building, we went afterwards,
we went for a drink.
And I was doing high
fives with the physicists
as the announcement came up
on the BBC News at 6 o'clock.
This is the very first email.
I keep writing
September the 14th.
I'm sorry about that.
That's the phrase.
"Hi all, cWB has just put on
gracedb a very interesting
event in the last hour."
OK.
If you want to find out what
all those technical terms mean,
you'll have to read the book.
It's all explained
in some detail.
But that was it.
But didn't excite
me particularly.
I just thought, oh, I'd
better save-- you see,
I'm always getting--
for years, been getting
dozens of emails a day
from the gravitational
wave community.
Every now and again, I think,
oh, that might be interesting.
I'll put them in
a separate folder.
But mostly, I just delete them
after reading the subject line.
But this one, I
thought, well, I'll
start putting these
in their own folder
and see how it fades out.
And you know, a couple
of months later,
I just reaffirmed that I was
not the only person thinking
like that.
So you can read that quote from
a gravitational wave physicist.
Now, he says, could it have
appeared so early in the run?
It's because the machines
weren't officially switched on.
They weren't supposed to
be officially switched
on for another few days.
What was going on was
an engineering run,
and they were still
being shaken down.
As it happens, that was an
extraordinarily lucky thing.
On the one hand, people
who were doubters-- well,
this shouldn't happen
in an engineering run.
And are we in a position to
make any claim with this, given
that it's an engineering run?
There'll be too much noise.
The machine won't
be steady enough.
People will have been
messing about with it.
But it turned out people hadn't
been messing about with it
just around the time,
and there was just
enough period of
smooth noise for them
to be able to do this--
for there to be enough
of that period for them
to be able to do
the calculations,
the statistical calculations
they needed to do.
So that was so early in the run.
But the great advantage of
it being so early in the run
is that it made it
very unlikely that this
was a blind injection.
Because that's what all the
physicists, by this time,
were fed up with.
They'd already spent
a lot of their lives
analyzing and investigating
blind injection.
And they didn't want
to have to investigate
another blind injection.
And they thought,
oh, no, this is
the management shoving it
another blind injection
to test us again.
And nobody knows what to do.
Because if you're
seriously investigating
gravitational waves,
your life changes.
You know, you stop talking
to your partner and family
and seeing your kids.
You're working like hell
to analyze the data.
And it's even worse
for me, because I'd
written two books about
blind injections, which
was a good thing.
That was fine.
I was happy about it.
But there was no way
I was going to write
a third about blind injection.
And that meant if it had
been a blind injection,
I would have been
wasting another three
months of my life.
Now, I spoke to the director
of the project, and said, look,
this is going to happen.
If you put in another
blind injection,
you better tell me, because
I can't spend another--
I'm too old to spend another
three months of my life messing
about with a blind injection.
And he kind of--
I think we had an
understanding that he would.
OK?
And then we worked out,
how am I going to keep it,
the fact that I know, a
secret from everybody else.
And I'll pretend that
I'm very ill so I can't
get on the planes to fly to
meetings, which I thought would
be necessary at that time.
It turned out not to be.
And we sort of had a nod
and a wink about that.
But because it happened
in this engineering run,
most people were ready to
believe the directorate when
they sent around
an email saying,
no, this is not a
blind injection.
I mean, there was
a lot of paranoia.
There were people who
still didn't believe them
They thought, oh,
those bastards.
They're trying to test
us even more, you know.
But eventually,
people decided, well,
there's nothing we
can do about this.
We've got to get on
with the analysis.
And I decided, if this turns out
to be a blind injection, that's
the last I'm going to
have to do with LIGO.
OK?
But it wasn't a blind injection.
And I was reassured
by the fact--
five minutes.
Oh, I'm going to take a bit
longer than my promised half
hour.
OK?
Is that all right?
So it was OK.
Then the other thing
that people started
to do-- so you've
got this signal.
Do you believe it or not?
Well, I will tell
you that remarkably--
and this was
completely astonishing,
given the paranoia
that was around--
that it only took about two days
before people began to believe
this was a real signal.
Once they dismissed
the idea of--
they hadn't yet dismissed
the idea of blind injection.
And the other thing that
everybody was worried about
was it a malicious hack.
Was it some clever
malicious people
from Google who
got into the system
and injected something
which appeared
to be a gravitational wave
into the big machines?
And one of the big efforts
was to work out, well,
what would it take to do?
Is it credible that somebody
could have hacked into it
and done this?
And the conclusion
was, no, it wasn't.
It would have required
too big a conspiracy,
and it couldn't be done.
People were reasonably
satisfied with that notion.
Though the idea of a
malicious hack, or a hack,
is still around among the fringe
scientists who don't believe
this.
So that was another thing
that spent a lot of time.
And then the analysis
starts, you know.
The belief, that
belief in two days,
came because the signal produced
a very nice waveform, which
very nicely matched the
signal from an inspiraling
binary pair of black holes.
And the waveform
overlapped very nicely
on the two detectors,
the one at Hanford
and the one at Livingston, a
couple of thousand miles apart.
And that got people
to believe it.
But that's not good enough
for the physics community.
For the physics
community, you have
to show that the unlikelihood
of this being due to chance
is about one in 3.5 million.
That's the five-sigma standard.
There's a whole
sociological story
about how that sigma,
how that standard changed
in physics from three-sigma
in the 1960s up to five-sigma
in the 2000s, which is
also discussed in the book.
So that's the signal.
That's the figure from
the first publication.
That's a slightly simpler
and more easy to understand
version of it, which I
got one of the physicists
to draw for me.
And you can see--
oh, you've got to
do a few things.
So that's what the signal from
one of these overlapping--
sorry, inspiraling
binary neutron stars
ought to look like.
OK?
This is more like what it
would look like on the machine.
You've got to take into
account the sensitivity
of the machine at the various
different frequencies.
And these are the actual
signals from the machine.
And they overlap very
nicely, as you can see here.
OK?
And if you take that
overlapping signal out,
this is what you get left.
And it looks like noise.
Therein lies a story.
Does anybody know--
I'm doing a piece of
sociological fieldwork now.
Has anybody heard of
any recent objections
to the validity of
this finding by LIGO?
Yeah.
Anybody else?
That's one person.
You've heard of it.
Yeah.
OK.
Yeah, see, I really
want to know this.
Really, put your hands up
high because I want to count.
One, two, three, four, five.
OK, five people
in a room of 100.
Yeah, something like that.
And what they found
out, these people
who were making the
recent objection,
is they've analyzed this.
And they found out that there
is an overlapping signal here.
And there is
leftover because when
the subtraction was
made of this from this,
it wasn't done quite right.
And so there is, in fact, a
bit of overlapping signal here.
But for some reason,
these objectors
have decided that the fact
that there's an overlapping
signal there means that the
original detection can't
be trusted.
Nobody in LIGO thinks this is in
any way a reasonable objection.
And for what my
opinion is worth,
I don't think it is either.
But it's interesting
sociologically
and bears very nicely on
the difference between what
you know when you
are inside a team
and what you know when
you're outside a team.
Because the objectors
are outside the team.
And they, as most people
think, don't know how
to analyze the signal properly.
And that goes back to
my little experiment
on the narrow crevasse-like
nature of science.
Just the difference
between how you
come to believe in a signal,
which was the overlapping
waveforms, and what you have
to do to prove it to the wider
scientific community,
you could read
that quotation from one of the
gravitational wave physicists.
They did a little jiggery-pokery
with the statistics.
Everybody was agonizing,
was this legitimate,
or what was this
statistical massage
concluded it wasn't statistical
massage, what they did was OK.
And I believe it was OK as well.
But you see there's a nice
thought about it from one
of my colleagues in the
gravitational wave physicist.
And you see how people
are worried about--
The reason I'm
putting out the quote
is you want to see the
difference between what
makes people believe
in something,
and what makes people
think about what
they have to do to convince
the wider scientific community.
The event and its
reception, that's
what was said at the
press conference.
"We have detected
gravitational waves.
We did it."
What nobody knew at
the time, and what
I was extremely cross
about, was that the reason--
one of the reasons anyway--
that the announcement was made
was such huge confidence
is because by that time,
they had already seen a second
gravitational wave, which
hit on Boxing Day,
2015, December the 26th.
But they decided as they hadn't
finished fully analyzing it,
they weren't going to mention
it in the discovery paper.
I thought this was deceitful,
and it was falsifying history.
Because the real-- there
have been cases in physics
before where a single event
has turned out to be wrong.
The most famous one is
that magnetic monopole.
And during the course
of this whole event,
people were saying,
oh, let's hope
this isn't another
magnetic monopole.
And then on December the
26th, the Boxing Day after,
a little bit of analysis
had been done on it.
And there was a
great sigh of relief.
Thank heaven we
found a second one.
But that wasn't mentioned in the
discovery announcement, which
it seemed to me to
be completely wrong.
The title of the paper, that
was the title of the paper,
"Observation of Gravitational
Waves From a Binary Black Hole
Merger."
and it really did, when I
was not in sociological mode,
but scientific mode, send
cold shivers down my spine
to imagine this would happen
after I'd been hanging
about for over 44 years.
This is the event.
A billion-and-a-half years
ago, a billion-and-a-half light
years away, two black holes of
masses 36 and 29 solar masses
collided, losing three
suns' worth of mass,
which was totally converted
into gravitational wave energy.
Compare that three
suns' worth of mass
with about a gram
converted into energy
for the first atomic
bomb, five pounds
from the biggest hydrogen
bomb that's ever been made.
If the energy had been emitted
as electromagnetic radiation,
it would have been brighter
than the full moon,
even though it was a
billion-and-a-half light years
away, brighter than the full
moon for just a fraction
of a second.
And if it happened
where our sun was,
it would have evaporated the
solar system in an instant.
But as the energy was emitted
as gravitational waves--
remember I said how faint it is,
faint gravitational radiation
is-- if you'd been at
a distance of our sun
from this huge
emission of energy,
all you would have
noticed would have
been a slight bang in your
ears as the bones in your ears
were moved slightly by the
gravitational wave passing by.
You wouldn't have
noticed it otherwise.
The effect on the four-kilometer
interferometer arms,
changes in the length of one
arm as compared to the other,
down to 1/10,000th of the
diameter of a proton, small,
which I worked out.
Now, I live in Cardiff.
That's Cardiff Bay taken
from what was then my study.
Cardiff Bay is about a
square mile of water.
What you were looking for was
a rise in the level of Cardiff
Bay, which would have been
caused by the addition
of 1/1,000 of a drop of water.
And that's why I said it's
the most sensitive instrument
that's probably ever been built.
Here's the press conferences.
Here's the newspaper headlines.
There's a song to the tune
of "I'm a Believer" written
by some of the physicists.
[LAUGHTER]
There's the huge spike
in Google Trends, which
shows that the whole
population has suddenly
become fascinated by
gravitational waves,
but not as fascinated as
they are in Kim Kardashian--
[LAUGHTER]
--which was checked
out at the same time.
It's about 2% of Kim
Kardashian's peak
and completely invisible
by Kim Kardashian's
average popularity.
[LAUGHTER]
OK?
A few more things.
How do we know
it's true nowadays?
Well, we don't.
Discoveries in physics
are social changes.
And one of the reasons these
social changes come about
is because you know when
to stop questioning.
There's all kinds of doubts
you can still think up.
OK?
The whole thing depends on
trust and a reasonable level
of questioning.
On the day of the
press announcements,
this was announced in CERN.
And I listened to the recording
of the announcement in CERN.
And somebody said, how do we
know that the gravity waves
travel at the speed of light?
Because if they don't travel
at the speed of light,
all bets are off.
How do we know they travel
at the speed of light?
The whole observation
is consistent
with them traveling
at the speed of light.
But we've never
had any real proof.
And somebody put up their
hand from the audience
and said, look, if you carry
on questioning like this,
we'll soon have uninvented
the Higgs boson.
OK?
And that's right.
That's the reason
you stop questioning,
because if you question deeply
enough, everything collapses.
Undiscover the Higgs.
Then there's a whole lot of
stuff with the fringe, who
were criticizing it.
The fringe don't believe it.
I was in touch with
fringe scientists
and corresponding with them.
And the reason was--
well, I'd better stop actually.
Otherwise, we won't
have time for questions.
We can always come back to
these slides if you want.
But I'll stop there.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: We do have
time for questions.
Please wait for the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Why did you pick
gravitational waves community
to study?
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: Pure coincidence.
I was doing my PhD.
I had already done a study
of scientific communication
among people building
a new kind of laser,
the transversely excited
atmospheric pressure CO2 laser.
I wanted a more competitive
field to compare it with.
I read about the controversy
in the "New Scientist."
And I thought, that'll do me.
I picked one or
two others as well.
AUDIENCE: And is there a
community of sociologists
doing equivalent work?
Is there someone embedded in
the Higgs boson community,
for example?
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: Well,
there are sociologists
going around studying
other bits of science.
I'm trying to encourage
more of this kind of work
to be done because I think
it's very important that people
outside of the technical
scientific community
have a really deep
understanding of science.
AUDIENCE: How much does
this observatory cost?
And when you take the whole
scientific budget, the budget
allocated for the scientific
research, fundamental research,
how much is allocated for
this particular device?
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: OK,
well, the whole lot, you
can say nowadays, by now, it's
cost about a billion dollars.
I don't know how that compares
with the scientific budget
as a whole.
One of the problems
for the interferometers
was being so expensive.
I should have said they were
funded by the US National
Science Foundation.
And it was the biggest
experiment the National Science
Foundation had ever funded.
Now, high energy
physics is mostly funded
by the Department of Energy.
And they have a lot more money.
So the trouble
with gravity waves
is it had an impact on
the many scientists doing
much smaller experiments
which were funded by the NSF.
So it became very unpopular
among a large constituency.
But when people ask
me how much it costs,
I always say, well, probably
about the same as the wing
of a stealth fighter.
You know, compare it
with military budgets
to put it in
perspective, I think.
AUDIENCE: There must be similar
ones built all around the world
also, right?
I heard in India, they
are building one there.
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does it make sense
to spend that much money there?
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: Yeah,
in India, they're now--
and there's been a long
negotiation over this.
They're building the
infrastructure for it,
the beam tubes and
the foundations
and the buildings in India.
But the interferometer parts
are coming from America,
because when initial
LIGO was built,
they built three interferometers
within the beam tubes for two.
And they're taking the third
one, and that's going to India.
Why does it make sense?
Well, why does the
whole thing makes sense?
It makes sense because
it's a fantastic
confirmation of Einstein's
general theory of relativity.
But it also makes sense
if you like astronomy.
Because where it goes
is the foundation
of a new gravitational
wave astronomy, which
enables you to see
things that you can't see
with electromagnetic astronomy.
So you can pretty
well look directly
at black holes, which can't
be seen any other way.
So this phenomenon
that was discovered,
the inspiraling of two
black holes, nobody
knew if such things existed.
So there were two discoveries,
the first discovery
of gravitational waves and the
first discovery of inspiraling
binary black holes.
Why do we need
another one in India?
Well, what the ideal is is
to move this astronomy along
so that you can see
a gravitational wave
and compare its
position in the sky,
look at its position
in the sky with
electromagnetic telescopes.
And for that reason, you've
got to know its position
in the sky.
And the only way to know
its position in the sky
is by triangulation
of the time of arrival
of the event on widely
separated instruments.
At the moment, with
only two instruments,
you get a huge area on the sky
where it could have come from.
There's a third one,
actually, in Italy,
which is just coming online.
And then with the
India one, there
will be four, fairly
widely separated.
And you may be able to
narrow down the position
in the sky more narrowly then.
And then your
gravitational astronomy
will get better and better.
AUDIENCE: With hindsight,
we can certainly
tell that the first 40
years of interferometers
were clearly not
sensitive enough.
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: Well,
it's not 40 years
of interferometers, 40 years--
AUDIENCE: 40 years of detectors.
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Was there any
acknowledgement at the time
that this might be the case?
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: Yeah.
I mean, Joe Weber, who
I interviewed in '72,
told me that when he
built this apparatus,
he didn't expect
to see anything.
Because everybody knew it
was not sensitive enough
by a factor of 1,000 million.
And the question
is, what do you do
when you appear to
make a discovery which
ought to be impossible?
Do you say, oh, forget about it,
it's theoretically impossible?
Or do you say,
well, maybe we need
to think rethink our
theories through?
And a lot of people did start
rethinking their theories
and find ways to make
Joe Weber's findings
compatible with theory, like
focusing of gravitational waves
by some curious mechanism.
So there's a dilemma there.
And that dilemma was played
out among the people who
put experiment first and the
people who put theory first.
So everybody knew
that in theory,
at least in the initial theory,
these instruments were far too
insensitive to see anything.
But the determined
experimentalists still
felt, well, if I've
seen something,
I'm going to report it.
AUDIENCE: Do you see any
sociological parallels
between the whole field of
gravitational waves and people
on both sides of it
to climate science?
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: Oh, yes.
As I said, I did my first
lot of interviews in 1972
and then another lot
of interviews in '75.
Well, in '72-- in 1974, I wrote
the paper that emerged out
of the 1972 fieldwork.
And the big claim in
that paper, the reason
I got a secure university
job and had a stellar career
subsequently was
the observation I
made that there was something
called the experimenter's
regress.
And the experimenter's
regress goes like this.
Scientists say,
well, if you want
to know whether
something is true or not,
you have to replicate it.
And I think that's correct.
But the trouble is, how
do you know whether you
replicated something or not?
So the people who copied Joe
Weber's experiment, or roughly
copied it, said, look, we've
built an apparatus like yours,
Joe, and we don't see anything.
And Joe Weber said
to them, that's
because you haven't
built it right.
And that's not an
unreasonable claim,
because doing an experiment
is very, very, very, very
difficult. Think about the
experiments you did at school.
They never worked mostly.
[LAUGHTER]
OK?
You have to be told
by the school teacher
that they weren't
working, and you
had to keep on repeating them
until you got them to work.
And this is what Joe Weber
said the other people needed
to be doing.
Yeah?
So what happens is if you
look at what happened in '72
and for a few years
afterwards, the argument
turned from, has
this been repeated,
to who's competent to repeat it.
Who's the most
competent experimenter?
Is it Joe Weber?
Or is it his rivals?
And then when you
get this idea--
you see it happens all the time,
cold fusion, climate change.
Yes, you can put this
template onto climate change
and it works very well.
I mean, the next problem you
have, having done all that,
is to say, well,
how do we come down
on the right side
of climate change.
And I've been involved in a
huge row since the early 2000s
with my colleagues, because we
put forward the view that we
have to shift our attention
in social studies of science
from how do you reach
the truth to how
do you decide who's an expert.
And you should always
listen to the experts,
whether they're right or wrong.
Because otherwise, your
society is going to collapse,
and you're going
to have a dystopia.
And fortunately, my
friend Donald Trump
has come along to help
my views get salient.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks very much for your talk.
I was just curious.
You mentioned before
about how black holes
can't be observed any other
way, except gravitational waves.
So how did they know
when they observed
these gravitational waves
that they were two black holes
rotating?
Is it because they had the
theoretical model of what
the gravitational
waves would look like
and this kind of matched it?
Or was there some other
way that they knew
these black holes were there?
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: No.
It's a good question.
So two things.
Yeah, firstly, you've
got this model,
which took years and years
and decades to work out,
which did match it.
But then at the time, people
were saying that maybe they're
not black holes.
Maybe they're boson stars.
Boson stars weigh about
the same as black holes.
OK?
But who's ever
seen a boson star?
We've seen it even
less than a black hole.
This is just a figment of
theoretical physicists'
imagination.
You can imagine anything.
And I'm tearing out
my hair, saying,
oh, no, not boson stars.
We don't want boson stars.
For heaven's sake, let's
have a discovery at last.
I want to die having
reported a discovery.
And the boson star
thing faded away.
But it's one of those
things you could still ask.
You could still ask, has
it really been black holes?
And people could still
argue, no, it's boson stars.
It's one of those
places where you say,
time to stop questioning, OK?
Then there was another
nice little argument
produced for why they
had to be black holes.
They could tell how
far apart these things
were just before they collided
from the speed of rotation.
And they knew how
much they weighed also
from that kind of thing.
And you could work
out that nothing
that wasn't very
compact could get
that close without touching.
And that was another argument
for them being black holes.
So it's a good question, because
the argument is still not
completely settled.
But it's settled if
you're a physicist
and you want to be called
kind of reasonably sane.
AUDIENCE: Have you now finished
with the gravitational wave
community?
Or what are you
going to do next?
I don't know if
anything else is still
going on that you're studying?
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: Well, that's
a very good question again,
because I thought I'd finished.
I decided this was
the time to finish.
Nothing as exciting
as this is ever
going to happen to me in
my life studying again,
in my life studying physicists.
And I've kind of
corralled somebody else
to carry on after me looking
at gravitational waves physics
and continuing to write
the detailed history of it,
because I don't want
it to stop suddenly.
But this business about
these guys objecting to it
is really interesting from a
sociological point of view.
So I've found myself getting
sucked into it again.
And I'll probably write
a bit more about it
before I do completely finish.
SPEAKER: We are
unfortunately out of time.
We have time for
one more question.
AUDIENCE: Hopefully,
a quick question then.
And so if expertise
is very narrow,
going back to your
chart at the beginning,
but we should identify the
experts and believe them,
right or wrong, do those two
things make life difficult
when you put them together?
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: I don't think so.
I mean, there's another whole
element of which experts
you believe in.
You also have to believe only
in decent, honest experts.
And there's plenty of
non-decent, dishonest experts
around.
But you need a different
kind of argument--
I mean, a different kind
of investigative technique
to find out who those are.
I mean, the instant
that I always
use as my touchstone in how
to think about these things
is the mumps, measles,
and rubella vaccination
controversy.
And this is one
of the things that
got me started in being
hated by lots of people
in social studies of
science because I noticed
that many of my
colleagues in the field
wanted to defend the parents'
right not to vaccinate
their children during the course
of the mumps, measles, rubella
controversy.
And my view was that
that was terrible,
and that, in fact, parents had
to vaccinate their children.
And the reason is,
if you look at what
Andrew Wakefield,
a the person who
started the whole controversy,
said, if you look at his paper
in "The Lancet"--
I was reading it just
the other day actually.
He had no evidence at
all that mumps, measles,
and rubella vaccine
were linked to autism.
There's lots of allusions and
asides in that original paper.
But the paper says,
we haven't proved it.
And he certainly
hadn't proved it.
And if you allow a panic
like this to arise,
which was very much
amplified by the press,
who have a view that they should
always tell a balanced story--
well, their balanced
story was about--
on the one side were
parents, poor things,
who'd seen their children
become autistic a little while
after receiving the MMR vaccine.
And the other side
of the balance
was the huge
epidemiological studies
which showed that nowhere where
MMR vaccine had been introduced
into countries was there any
increase in the instance of MMR
in a population.
And the latter thing is
the end of the story.
The parents were always going
to see some children becoming
autistic after
they'd been injected
with MMR, because both things
happen at about same age.
OK?
And there would
be an equal number
of children who nobody
would be talking about,
who would have received the MMR
just after becoming autistic.
But nobody was
talking about them.
So all this balancing in the
newspapers and so on was wrong.
And one of the arguments
that really infuriated me
by one of my colleagues
was, well, look,
there is a possibility that
some small subset of children
who are peculiarly
vulnerable in some way
were affected by
the MMR vaccine.
The epidemiological
statistics are too large scale
to deal with that.
And of course, he
was absolutely right.
But you could make
exactly the same argument
for whether people became
autistic just after they'd
eaten a kiwi fruit for the first
time or anything else you like.
So if you allow this kind
of non-expert inference
from observational statistics
to enter the public domain,
you can waste all your national
health service money on scares
and never get anywhere.
I mean, the whole
argument is always
carried out under the
constraint of scarcity.
And so it's not a question
of what's absolutely
right in the long term.
It probably is the case
that one or two kids
are vulnerable to MMR.
But it's no good saying it.
It doesn't get you
to the policy answer.
So that's my answer
to your question.
Does it answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROF.
HARRY COLLINS: OK.
SPEAKER: Thank you very much,
Professor Harry Collins.
[APPLAUSE]